.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Ruhige Musik *
Die Malediven.
Für viele Inbegriff eines Traums:
weisse Sandstrände, Luxusresorts und
eine paradiesische Unterwasserwelt.
Doch auch hier gibt es sie,
die toten Riffe.
Durch steigende Wassertemperaturen,
Bauprojekte und Fischerei
sind heute bereits 50 %
aller Korallenriffe weltweit
zu Steinwüsten verkommen.
Menschen zerstören.
Aber es gibt auch solche,
die wiederaufbauen.
Der Basler Aki Allahgholi
und sein Team
retten Korallen
und forsten Riffe auf.
Mein ersten Projekt
war so ein Korallentisch.
Das machte ich mit dem letzten Geld,
das ich auf dem Sparkonto hatte.
Ich sagte: "Das ist es."
Ich spürte,
dass es in die Richtung gehen muss.
Das war ein Urinstinkt in mir.
Ich wollte das so stark.
Ich sagte: "Okay,
ich nehme das Risiko auf mich."
Der ehemalige Banker hat sein
Luxusleben in der Schweiz aufgegeben,
um auf der ganzen Welt
Korallen zu pflanzen.
Aus dem einstigen Lebemann
und Banker Aki Allahgholi
wurde der Korallengärtner.
Hier in Soneva Fushi,
wo andere Luxusferien machen,
arbeitet das Korallenteam
seit einem Monat auf Hochtouren.
Sechs Tage in der Woche
Schwerstarbeit.
Wir entscheiden,
wie wir uns am Nachmittag fühlen.
Also nur ein Tauchgang heute Morgen?
- Ja, okay.
Die vielen Tauchgänge dieses Monats
gehen langsam
an die Substanz des Teams.
Und trotzdem
bleibt die Faszination fürs Tauchen.
Freiheit.
Dann sehe ich die Korallen,
die Nursery ...
Und auf einmal kommt vielleicht
irgendwie ein Rochen vorbei
oder eine Turtle.
Dann ist man einfach happy.
Voll easy.
Aki Allahgholi hat die NGO Coralive
im Jahr 2016 gegründet.
Über zehn Projekte in aller Welt
hat er schon initiiert.
Dieses hier auf den Malediven
ist mit Abstand das grösste bisher.
15'000 Korallen
sollen hier gepflanzt werden.
Jetzt haben wir
den ersten Morgentauchgang.
Da vorne sieht man das Boot
mit den Korallen.
Die warten schon sehnsüchtig
auf uns.
Sein Team besteht
aus jungen Biologen und Biologinnen
aus der ganzen Welt -
aus Australien,
Belgien, Schottland und der Schweiz.
Jeden Tag bringen lokale Fischer
ca. 500 Korallen.
In einem speziellen Fischerboot
haben sie diese
über 100 km hierhin transportiert.
Damit die heikle Fracht überlebt,
muss das Wasser innerhalb des Bootes
ständig zirkulieren.
Normalerweise werden diese Boote
für den Transport lebendiger Fische
genutzt.
Good man.
Die Korallen wurden
vor einer Grossbaustelle gerettet.
In der Nähe der Hauptstadt Male baut
der Staat einen neuen Handelshafen.
Um Land zu gewinnen,
wird dort ein Riff zugeschüttet.
Wenn wir jetzt nichts machen,
würden sie in zwei Monaten
komplett mit Sand überschüttet.
Wirtschaftlicher Erfolg bzw.
Wachstum ist natürlich wichtiger ...
... als der Schutz
von so wichtigen Korallen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Die Korallen
müssen sich nun vom Transport erholen
und an die neuen Bedingungen
gewöhnen:
Salzgehalt, pH-Wert,
Nährstoffe und Licht.
Auf den Tischen
werden sie zwischengelagert
und können dann nach ein paar Monaten
ins Riff gepflanzt werden.
Aus rund 430 solcher Tische
besteht der Korallengarten.
Er hat Platz für 50'000 Korallen.
Es ist
nicht nur Akis grösstes Projekt,
sondern auch ein aussergewöhnliches.
Ganze Korallenkolonien zu verpflanzen
ist selten möglich.
Normalerweise
müssen aus kleinen Korallenstücken
zuerst grosse Korallen
gezüchtet werden.
Das Spezielle an dieser Technik:
Die Korallentische
werden mit ganz wenig Strom versorgt.
Das erhöht den pH-Wert
und macht das Meereswasser
rund um die Tische kalkhaltiger.
Kalk
ist das Baumaterial der Korallen.
Der Strom schafft also eine Umgebung,
die sich positiv
auf das Wachstum auswirkt.
So wachsen sie doppelt so schnell.
Das Fischchen noch retten.
Korallen sind die Grundlage.
Wenn die Grundlage
eines marinen Ökosystems stimmt ...
... können auch alle anderen -
Delfine, Rochen und Schildkröten -
davon profitieren.
Darum ist es für mich
am wichtigsten,
dass man sich
um diese "Tiere" kümmert.
Ah!
Table for two. Woo-hoo-hoo!
Für sein Riesenprojekt ist Aki
einen Deal mit einem Luxushotel
eingegangen.
Der staatliche Bau
des neuen Hafens in Male
soll wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung
und noch mehr Tourismus ermöglichen.
Dafür wird aber ein Riff zerstört.
Ist das jetzt ein Herzensprojekt?
Alles, was mit Korallen zu tun hat,
ist ein Herzensprojekt.
Aber dies ist eher ein Projekt ...
... an dem die Tourismusbranche
Interesse zeigte:
Das Korallenriff etwas aufzubessern.
Dementsprechend
arbeiten wir nicht gratis.
Aber alles, was wir ...
... machen können, um den Korallen
zu helfen, ist ein Herzensprojekt.
Also:
Ja, es ist auch ein Herzensprojekt.
Nach einer Stunde
sind die Korallen ausgeladen.
Jetzt taucht auch noch der Chef ab
und hilft dem Team dabei,
die Fragmente anzubinden.
* Verträumte Musik *
Aus diesen Fragmenten
sollen in ungefähr einem Jahr
grosse Korallenkolonien entstehen.
* Verträumte Musik *
Nach über einer Stunde unter Wasser
haben wieder ein paar Korallen
ein neues Zuhause gefunden.
* Verträumte Musik *
Coralive wurde vom Luxushotel
mit der Aufforstung beauftragt.
Das Projekt verfügt über ein Budget
von 300'000 Fr. -
finanziert vom Hotel und von Spenden.
Ein neues Hausriff
lässt man sich hier einiges kosten.
Das Korallenteam ist vorübergehend in
einem freien Bungalow einquartiert.
Ganz schön luxuriös,
wie selten bei seinen Projekten.
Wer als Hotelgast
hier übernachten will,
bezahlt im Minimum 1'500 Fr. -
pro Nacht.
Mit Bart Knols und Morgane Dierkens
bespricht Aki den kommenden Abend.
Wir müssen es wagen,
gross zu denken.
Nicht mit ein paar Stückchen
Korallen rumalbern.
Ich bin sowieso zu gross
für Small Talk.
Und was ist mit mir?
Aki bekommt die Möglichkeit,
an einem exklusiven Apéro
für geladene Hotelgäste
sein Projekt zu vermarkten.
Geldbeschaffung da, wo
mehr als ausreichend vorhanden ist.
Für eine NGO eine attraktive Option.
Sogar tote Korallen faszinieren
und werfen bei Angestellten vor Ort
Fragen auf.
Wie lange behalten sie die Farbe?
Die Farbe ist nicht echt.
Die haben wir aufgesprüht.
Es soll
ein bisschen künstlich aussehen.
Wenn sie sterben,
bleibt nur noch das Gerüst übrig.
Das lebende Gewebe,
das der Koralle die Farbe gibt,
ist eine Alge.
Die Alge lebt in Symbiose
mit dem Polypen, der ein Tier ist.
Ah, eine gute, schnelle Erklärung.
- Beautiful.
Auf einer Sandbank
wird für die exquisite Kundschaft
einmal pro Woche ein
Sonnenuntergangsapéro organisiert.
Akis Ziel ist es, Patenschaften
für Korallentische zu verkaufen.
Noch vor wenigen Jahren betreute er
Bankkunden aus diesen Kreisen.
Wie gerne machst du solche Events?
Ja, ja, ich bin lieber im Wasser
mit den Korallen.
Aber es ist halt genauso wichtig ...
... diese Dinge zu machen,
damit die Leute wissen, was wir tun.
"Tue Gutes und rede davon."
Das sagte mal mein Chef
bei der Bank.
Es ist halt schon wichtig,
dass man das kommuniziert.
Hilft es auch,
dass du bei der Bank gearbeitet hast
und die Leute und Gesellschaft
ein bisschen kennst?- Ja, ja.
Unter Wasser wird dann ein Schildchen
mit dem Namen des Paten
an den Tisch gehängt.
Preis: 1'000 Fr. pro Tisch.
Prost. Mal schauen, wie es läuft.
- Ja.
Bart sagte, mindestens drei.
Und fünf wären toll.
Ich glaube an dich.
Ah, nur kein Druck, oder?
- Genau.
Die ersten kommen schon.
Diskretion wird in diesen Kreisen
grossgeschrieben.
Die Kamera
hat auf Distanz zu bleiben.
Die Kaufbereitschaft
ist aber eher bescheiden.
Ja ...
Wir reden viel über das,
was wir machen ...
... aber keiner nimmt das Scheckbuch
raus und kauft fünf Stück.
Mal schauen. Es ist das erste Mal.
Es ist okay.
Ist das ein bisschen enttäuschend?
- Ja ...
Ich habe es so erwartet.
Ein paar Tage später
kauft ein Gast doch noch zwei Tische.
Alles läuft diskret ab.
Aki kennt sich aus,
auch wenn er vor 14 Jahren dieser
Gesellschaft den Rücken gekehrt hat.
Irgendwann habe ich mich mal
im Spiegel angeschaut.
Ich hatte so tiefe Augenringe
und mein Gesicht war eingefallen.
Ich war bleich, fühlte mich schwach
und konnte nicht mehr schlafen.
Das waren die ersten Anzeichen,
die ich zum Glück ...
... auch wahrnehmen konnte.
Meistens sagen die Menschen:
"Dann nimmst du halt mehr Vitamine
oder irgendwelche Medikamente,
um das zu überbrücken."
Dann geht es wieder weiter
und der Chef kommt und sagt:
"Du musst das durchziehen,
das ist wichtig."
"Wir haben Deadlines."
Und das Individuum
bleibt einfach auf der Strecke.
Basel.
Einmal pro Jahr kommt Aki
für ein, zwei Monate in die Schweiz.
Es ist immer wieder gut,
nach Basel zurückzukommen.
Ich komme von hier.
Hier hat alles angefangen.
Daher ... Doch ...
Es ist immer wieder
ein gutes Gefühl.
Aki ist in Basel
als Sohn eines Iraners
und einer Schweizerin aufgewachsen,
hat Wirtschaft und Informatik
studiert
und eine steile Karriere
bei der Bank Sarasin hingelegt.
Gleichzeitig hat er
in der Basler Partyszene mitgemischt.
In diesem Gebäude zuoberst,
im Messeturm,
war meine Bar, die ich führte.
Wir hatten sehr viel Spass.
Wir haben sehr viel erlebt.
Wir hatten Konzerte.
Ich erinnere mich, dass ich damals
hauptsächlich in der Nacht lebte.
Leistung, Ansehen, Geld und Ehrgeiz
prägten sein Leben.
Den Tag durch trug ich meinen Anzug
und sass an meinem Computer,
abends fuhr ich
mit meiner fetten Karre in die Bar
und schaute dort nach dem Rechten.
Und das Wochenende über
machte ich Party in der Bar.
Meistens schlief ich vom Sonntag-
morgen, als ich nach Hause kam,
bis am Montagmorgen durch,
und dann ging es weiter.
Da wohnte ich eine Zeit lang,
als ich bei der Bank arbeitete.
Ich war schon ewig nicht mehr hier.
Das ist alles in der Vergangenheit.
Alles abgeschlossen.
Vor 14 Jahren wurde das alles
zu viel und endete in einem Burn-out.
Um sich selbst, einen Sinn und
einen neuen Weg im Leben zu finden,
ging Aki drei Jahre auf Reisen.
In Madagaskar kam er als Volunteer
zum ersten Mal in Kontakt
mit Korallenaufforstung.
Ich mache kurz einen Kaffee.
Wenn er in der Schweiz ist,
wohnt er bei Freunden
oder der Mutter,
aber einen festen Wohnsitz
hat er keinen mehr.
Der 46-Jährige
ist Single und kinderlos.
Im Moment zählen nur die Korallen.
Seit sechs Jahren
ist er in der ganzen Welt
unterwegs für seine Projekte.
Ha, so geil!
Wenn man den Flug bei Ethiopian
übers Internet kauft,
kostet er 720 Euro
und über die App 683 Euro.
Sauerei!
Ist das nicht ein bisschen
Wasser in den Rhein getragen,
wenn man so viel rumfliegt?
- Ja, ja.
Sämtliche Flüge,
die wir in der Organisation machen,
werden kompensiert -
mit Carbon Credits,
also mit CO2-Zertifikaten.
Sämtliche Kilometer
bzw. sämtliches CO2,
das für den Weg produziert wird,
den wir machen, wird neutralisiert.
Das ist ja grundsätzlich
eine Ausrede.
Es hilft schon.
Ich kenne die Organisation,
mit der wir zusammenarbeiten
und die wir
für die CO2-Ausstösse bezahlen.
Ich weiss,
in welche Projekte das Geld fliesst.
Damit werden Mangroven gepflanzt,
die wirklich unglaublich stark sind
in der Bindung von CO2.
Ja, auf eine Art ist es schon
ein bisschen ein "Greenwashing".
Aber ich kenne die Projekte,
in die das Geld fliesst.
Daher: ja und nein.
Die Zeit in der Schweiz
nutzt er auch,
um neue Projekte aufzugleisen,
Kontakte zu knüpfen oder zu pflegen.
Ist Schweizerdeutsch okay?
- Ja.
Okay, kein Hochdeutsch.
Marc Kaiser, ein alter Freund,
hat ihm eine Vortragsmöglichkeit
beim Rotary Club verschafft.
Nicht alle Projekte
haben einen so potenten Geldgeber
wie das auf den Malediven.
Aki sucht Geld
für ein Projekt in Madagaskar.
Vor der Präsentation
bleibt noch etwas Zeit,
um auf die gemeinsame Reise
in Argentinien zurückzublicken.
Dort schloss ich den Pakt
mit der Natur:
"Du hast meinem Leben
frischen Wind gegeben,
und ich ändere mein Leben
und stelle es in deinen Dienst."
Dann fing ich an, zu verkaufen:
Ich löste die Wohnung,
die Leasings und Versicherungen auf.
Ich löste alles auf.
Das dauerte aber drei Jahre.
Das braucht schon Mut.
- Ja, schon.
Man kommt so schnell
wieder in diesen Trott rein.
Ich glaube,
der Mensch braucht eine Aufgabe.
Darum finde ich toll, was du machst.
Das gibt dir einen grösseren ...
Es hilft.
Es ist aber auch gefährlich.
Ich kann nicht aufhören zu arbeiten.
Die letzten fünf Jahre habe ich mich
komplett auf die NGO konzentriert
und das Tag und Nacht gelebt.
Ich blieb dabei
etwas auf der Strecke.
Ich selber als Mensch.
Jetzt muss ich etwas runterfahren.
Man kann auch mit einer NGO,
die an den schönsten Orten der Welt
arbeitet, ein Burn-out kriegen.
Ich habe ein paar Bilder, damit
man einen Eindruck davon erhält,
wie das Ganze aussieht.
Das ist der erste Monat,
vier Monate später,
zehn Monate später und noch mal
etwas mehr als ein Jahr später.
Innerhalb
von ungefähr zweieinhalb Jahren ...
Geld für die Korallenaufforstung
zu beschaffen, ist das eine,
den Lebensunterhalt zu bestreiten
das andere.
Bis jetzt
zahlt sich Aki keinen Lohn aus,
sondern investiert weiter
in Korallenprojekte.
Ah, warte schnell. Warte schnell.
In den Sommermonaten
arbeitet er auf dem Bau,
um seine privaten Ausgaben zu decken.
Zusammen
mit Arbeitskollege Martin Fritschi
baut er heute ein Fundament
für einen Schiessstand.
Du würdest viel mehr verdienen,
wenn du das machen würdest,
was du früher gemacht hast.
Damit hättest du
auch mehr Zeit für dein Projekt.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Es geht darum, ob man seine Zeit
dafür einsetzen will ...
... um Geld zu beschaffen
oder um ...
... zu leben.
... damit
etwas Sinnvolles zu machen.
Klar,
wenn wir Projekte umsetzen wollen,
braucht das alles Geld,
aber das ist eine andere Motivation.
Dann organisiert man Geld,
um ein Projekt zu machen,
das der Umwelt zugutekommt.
Auch hier gibt es v.a. ein Thema:
Korallen.
Wir nehmen die Korallen
und binden sie an einem Gerüst an.
Mit einem Metalldraht?
- Ja.
Rost ist nicht tragisch?
- Gibt es nicht. Es ist ja am Strom.
Aber irgendwann verrostet es, nicht?
- Nein.
Wenn der Strom fliesst,
kann es nicht rosten.
Die äusserste Schicht des Eisens
muss sich so nicht opfern
und oxidiert nicht.
Dann rostet es nicht.
Und die Fische
haben kein Problem damit?
Nein.
Da kommen Rochen und Haifische -
kein Problem.
Ja, ja.
Wie sieht es mit dem Loch aus?
Geht es mehr nach rechts
oder mehr nach links?
Weisst du das noch?
* Ruhige Musik *
* Sanfte Musik *
Zurück auf den Malediven.
Seit eineinhalb Monaten werden
täglich rund 500 Korallen geliefert.
Das Team arbeitet auf Hochtouren
und die Korallentische
werden immer voller.
Leben zieht ins Riff ein.
Die frischen Korallen
ziehen allerlei Tiere an -
wie z.B. Schildkröten und Oktopusse.
Sie machen das Riff
zu ihrem Zuhause.
* Verträumte Musik *
Auch die Papageifische werden
von den neuen Korallen angelockt -
nicht ganz unproblematisch
für das Korallenteam.
Sie ernähren sich von den Algen,
die in den Korallen leben.
Dementsprechend
beissen sie diese auch an.
Sie kommen von allen Seiten,
auch von unten.
Dann kann es sein, dass die
Korallenkolonien vom Tisch fallen.
Darum mussten wir
relativ schnell reagieren.
Immer, wenn
eine neue Korallenlieferung kam,
haben wir sie
auf unserer Struktur angebunden.
Die Papageifische nehmen beim Fressen
Kalksteinpartikel auf.
Weil sie den Kalk
nicht verdauen können,
scheiden sie ihn wieder aus.
Daraus entstehen die legendären
weissen Sandstrände der Malediven.
Inzwischen
sind fast alle Korallen transportiert
und auf den Tischen zwischengelagert.
In einem nächsten Schritt sollen die
Korallen ins Riff gepflanzt werden.
Alex Stead, der Projektmanager,
macht Tests -
unter anderem mit Zement.
Die Korallen
müssen am Riff fixiert werden,
um Sturm, Wellen und hungrigen Tieren
zu trotzen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Für den Feldversuch verwendet
das Team abgebrochene Korallenstücke.
Das Ziel ist, herauszufinden,
welche die schnellste,
günstigste und verträglichste Art
von Befestigung ist.
Zur Auswahl stehen Zement und Epoxy
oder man versucht, die Korallen
einfach in Löcher zu klemmen.
In ein paar Wochen wird sich zeigen,
welche Korallen noch leben
und am besten angewachsen sind.
Aber auch die beste Technik
ist keine Garantie,
dass die Korallen überleben werden.
Steigende Wassertemperaturen
und andere Umwelteinflüsse
belasten die empfindlichen Geschöpfe
schwer.
Das ursprüngliche Riff
ist 2016 infolge
einer Korallenbleiche abgestorben.
Wie sinnvoll ist es,
hier Korallen zu pflanzen,
wenn sie mal wegen Korallenbleiche
abgestorben sind?
Es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
Diese Korallenart gibt es in
diesem Atoll praktisch nicht mehr.
Wir hatten das Glück,
auswählen zu können,
welche Korallensorte
wir hierherbringen.
Die Korallen,
die wir eingesammelt haben,
stammen
aus relativ flachen Gewässern.
Wir haben sie
auf ungefähr 1-2 m eingesammelt.
Dort ist das Wasser
meistens sehr warm.
Sie haben sich also
seit dem letzten Bleaching Event
sehr stark
an die neuen Umstände gewöhnt.
Die sind also sehr resistent.
Es wird vorhergesagt,
dass es in rund zwei Monaten
vielleicht wieder
einen Bleaching Event geben sollte.
Wir werden sehen, ob sie es machen.
Ist es wirklich so einfach,
ein Riff umzusiedeln?
Am nächsten Morgen
hat Aki Neuigkeiten.
Ein kurzfristiges Ereignis
ändert die Pläne ein bisschen
für die nächsten zwei Tage.
Ich wurde gebeten, beim TED Talk
über unser Projekt zu sprechen.
Durch einen Zufall
erhält Aki die Möglichkeit,
an einem
internationalen Innovationsevent
seine Korallenmission
in die ganze Welt zu verbreiten.
Diese Chance will er packen.
Thank you, guys.
Good luck.
- Thank you.
Es hat sich verändert.
Am Anfang waren wir viel
zusammen am Strand und im Wasser,
haben alles zusammen gemacht, sind
rumspaziert und haben ausprobiert.
Aber je grösser die Projekte werden,
desto weniger sehen wir ihn.
Er organisiert die Logistik.
Aki muss nun im Eiltempo eine
15-minütige Präsentation vorbereiten.
Darum geht das Team
heute allein tauchen.
Bart Knols,
ein erfahrener TED Talker,
berät ihn noch kurz,
bevor es losgeht.
Was denken Sie:
Wie viel Banker ist noch in Aki?
Hm!
Nicht so viel.
Er ist zu weich.
Er ist kein Banker mehr.
Sonst hätte er keinen Karrierewech-
sel im Alter von 32 Jahren gemacht
und mit seinem letzten Geld
Korallen gekauft. Richtig?
Das war in Griechenland.
Ich darf das nicht laut sagen,
weil wir das
unter dem Radar gemacht haben.
Das ist der Banker.
Der Banker ist noch hier.
Ihr habt das
unter dem Radar gemacht?- Ja.
TED Talk -  d i e  Plattform
für innovative Ideen.
Da, wo sonst z.B. Elon Musk
oder Greta Thunberg
ihre Botschaften
in die Welt verbreiten.
Vor vielen Leuten aufzutreten,
ist sich Aki gewöhnt.
In seiner Jugend
war er ein Basketballtalent,
hat es bis
in die Schweizer Nationalmannschaft
und dann - mit 19 - in ein
College-Team in den USA geschafft.
Es fühlt sich ein bisschen wie vor
einem grossen Basketballspiel an.
Es liegt etwas Spannung in der Luft.
Alles ist angespannt.
Und ... ähm ...
Aber ... ähm ...
Das ist ... Ich brauche das einfach.
Diesen Kick zu haben, tut gut.
* Aufmunternde Rufe *
Please give it up
for Aki Allahgholi.
* Applaus, Jubel *
There's so much work out there.
Die Präsentationsgelegenheiten
sind heiss begehrt.
Live aufgezeichnet werden die Talks
schliesslich über die Onlineplattform
in die ganze Welt verbreitet.
Jetzt bin ich fast nervöser
als vorher.
Jetzt, wo es vorbei ist,
fange ich an zu zittern.
Ich muss nicht mehr funktionieren,
sondern kann wieder sein.
Aber hat es Spass gemacht?
- Ja, voll. Ich will noch mal.
Wir machen einen zweiten.
* Ruhige Musik *
Am nächsten Morgen.
Das Projekt geht langsam dem Ende zu.
Warum hast du Champagner dabei?
Heute ist
die letzte Korallen-Delivery.
Wir haben 15'000 Korallen
transportiert.
Und wenn alles gut kommt
und die Sterne es so wollen,
wie wir hoffen ...
... gibt es heute Abend
sogar noch einen Spawning Event.
Das ist etwas so Rares
und unglaublich Einzigartiges -
das muss man mit Champagner
feiern und festen.
Spawning heisst:
Die Korallen laichen.
Ein sehr seltenes Ereignis.
Es tritt jedes Jahr
nur in einzelnen Nächten auf.
Aber jetzt müssen zuerst die
letzten Korallen ausgeladen werden.
Mit dem Platzieren
der allerletzten Koralle
ist für Aki und sein Team
ein Meilenstein erreicht.
* Verträumte Musik *
Wenn sich die Korallen
heute Abend tatsächlich
auch noch fortpflanzen würden,
wäre das für Aki und das Projekt
wie ein Sechser im Lotto.
Dann, abends um 23 Uhr,
taucht das Team voller Hoffnung
in den Korallengarten ab.
Und tatsächlich:
Die Korallen laichen.
Mehrere Tausend orange Eier
stehen zum Abwurf bereit.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Nachdem die Ei- und Spermienbündel
freigesetzt wurden,
steigen sie langsam
an die Oberfläche.
Der Befruchtungsprozess beginnt.
Ist das der Anfang
eines neuen Korallenriffs?
Drei Monate später.
Aki ist kurz in der Schweiz -
mit schlechten Neuigkeiten.
Sturm, hohe Wassertemperaturen,
schlechte Wasserqualität
und ein Krankheitsausbruch
haben den Korallen zugesetzt.
Eine harte Landung in der Realität.
Hier sieht es perfekt gesund aus.
Und vier Tage später ist es ... Ja.
Da hat diese Disease
überhandgenommen
und die ganzen Korallen zerstört.
Es ist scary,
wie schnell es gehen kann
und wie ... wie ...
Man kann fast dabei zuschauen,
wie eine Koralle ...
... vor sich hin stirbt.
Und man kann wirklich
praktisch nichts machen.
Bei wie viel Prozent
ist das passiert?
Ja, also ...
Anfänglich waren es sicher 30-40 %.
Jetzt sind leider sicher über
die Hälfte der Korallen zerstört.
Ist es überhaupt sinnvoll,
noch weiterzumachen?
Auf jeden Fall.
Nein, davon lassen wir uns
nicht einschüchtern.
Wie gesagt:
Die Korallen, die das überleben,
haben einen unglaublichen ...
"Kampfgeist"
ist vielleicht das falsche Wort,
aber die sind enorm stark.
Die haben einen sehr guten
genetischen Fussabdruck.
Das sind die Korallen,
mit denen man weiterarbeiten will.
Wir machen einfach vorwärts
und hoffen,
dass wir mit denen
gute Resultate erzielen können.
Es scheint also nicht so einfach
zu sein,
ein Korallenriff umzusiedeln.
Aber Aki gibt nicht auf.
Das ist cool:
Die Turtle kommt immer wieder
und schaut, was wir machen.
Die begleitet uns bei der Arbeit.
Immerhin: Die Hälfte der Korallen
hat es geschafft.
Das macht Hoffnung.
Aki macht weiter,
denn jede Koralle zählt.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023